breaking news facebook and instagram are
considering getting into the nft game
now of course nfts have taken the world
by storm but facebook and instagram two
stalwarts incumbents of the legacy
technology industry they're not gonna
get left behind supposedly what they're
thinking about doing here is everything
from allowing you to take your nft and
use it as your profile picture also
creating a platform where you can meet
nfts where you can display them on your
profile and also be able to buy and sell
it have a marketplace for nfts as well
this would be a massive deal they bring
three plus billion users into the nft
market they have to give everyone
digital wallets and they have to build
tons and tons of infrastructure this
could be one of the biggest inflection
points for the nft market that we've
ever seen but the nft market isn't small
by any means a new report just came out
this morning that openc has already seen
over 4 billion of trading volume on
their platform that's one single
platform already seeing this we know
that coinbase is going to launch an nft
platform and many many other companies
are trying to figure out what their
strategy is this seems like we are just
getting started in the nft space
billions of dollars already being traded
on a single platform and a large company
like meadow with facebook and instagram
hot on their heels i love seeing these
legacy companies capitulate and have to
jump into this new digital world nfts
are at the earliest days and anyone
who's ignoring it just isn't looking at
the data